.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Jetzt gehen wir nach oben.
Eltern von Kindern mit Behinderungen
tragen eine schwere Bürde.
Oftmals
ist es aber weniger ihr Schicksal,
das diese Familien belastet,
sondern die Querelen
mit der Invalidenversicherung.
Wir wussten ja auch nicht ...
... dass wir bzw. meine Frau am
meisten Kraft darauf verwenden muss,
mit der IV Lösungen zu finden.
Man muss den Atem haben,
weil es um meine Tochter geht.
Ja, ja, ja.
Man hat sich für Kinder entschieden.
Man kann das nicht planen.
Man hat sie, wie sie sind.
Man nimmt die Herausforderung an.
Heb deinen Hintern!
Cederic Menzi
ist fünfeinhalb Jahre alt.
Seit seiner Geburt ist er körperlich
und kognitiv schwer beeinträchtigt.
Ich komme.
Nicht bewegen.
Jetzt bist du gut drin.
Welche körperlichen
Beeinträchtigungen hat er?
Seine rechte Seite ist durch
den Schlaganfall teilweise gelähmt
oder hat eine Überspannung.
D.h., dass das Gehen
für ihn nicht einfach ist?
Nein. Er lernte
auch erst letztes Jahr zu gehen.
Das war ...
... ungefähr im August,
als er damit anfing.
Er machte ein paar Schritte.
Und im September/Oktober
schaffte er es auch von sich aus,
selber zu gehen.
Im Oktober wurde er fünf Jahre alt.
Er war also gut fünf,
bis er endlich gehen lernte.
Cederic kann gehen.
Für dieses Wunder haben er
und seine Mutter hart gearbeitet.
Mami.
Du machst nichts am Lichtschalter.
Du weisst, dass ich das nicht mag.
Welche Medikamente sind das?
Das eine ist ein Antiepileptikum
und das andere ist Catapresan.
Er hatte
eine starke Verspannung hier
und das Medikament
entspannt die Muskeln etwas.
Es ist eigentlich
ein blutdrucksenkendes Medikament.
Es wird aber auch gerne
für Muskelverspannungen eingesetzt.
Komm mit.
Ursprünglich
hiess es im Kinderspital,
dass er wahrscheinlich
nie reden und gehen wird.
Seine ursprüngliche Prognose war,
dass er stark zerebral gelähmt
im Rollstuhl sitzen wird.
Das ist sicher auch,
um die Ärzte zu schützen.
Und er hat ja
einen riesigen Hirnschaden.
Durch den Schlaganfall
verlor er fast das halbe Hirn
und auf der anderen Seite
starb vorne auch ein Teil ab.
Rein davon ausgehend,
was er im Kopf verloren hat,
ist klar, dass die Prognosen
nicht wirklich gut sind.
Ob Cederic die ersten Tage
nach seiner Geburt überleben würde,
war mehr als ungewiss.
Noch im Bauch
seiner Mutter Charlotte Menzi
hatte er einen ersten Schlaganfall,
kurz vor der Geburt einen zweiten.
Seine Mutter
bangte allein um sein Leben -
noch während der Schwangerschaft
hatte sie sich
von Cederics Vater getrennt.
Ganz ehrlich:
Ich war brutal überfordert damit.
Auch mit dem Wissen, was er hat.
Dann kam die Frage,
ob ich das selber schaffe.
Irgendwo kommt man an diesen Punkt,
an dem man sein Kind sieht
und alles, was auf einen zukommt.
Da hat man nur noch Angst und Panik.
Weil ich alleine mit ihm war
und ihn auch alleine geboren hatte,
kam so am zweiten, dritten Tag
dann dieses Bewusstsein:
"Scheisse,
du musst dich zusammenreissen."
"Du bist das Einzige, was er hat.
Du musst. Du bist seine Mami."
"Er ist dein Kind -
egal, was er hat."
Gut.
Hier kommt der Nebel raus.
Selina Matter, neun Jahre alt.
Schläft sie jetzt?
- Sie schläft.
Sie ist sich das gewohnt,
das weckt sie nicht mehr.
Selina lebt mit ihren Eltern und
dem kleinen Bruder Dario in Luzern.
Selina, schau,
ich hänge dir das Mittagessen an.
Hm?
Selina hat das Rett-Syndrom.
Die Krankheit
führt zu einer Entwicklungsstörung
des Zentralnervensystems.
Freust du dich? Hm?
Selina kann weder selbstständig
sitzen noch gehen noch sprechen.
Nur Mädchen
sind vom Rett-Syndrom betroffen.
Die Diagnose
erhielten Isabelle und Toni Matter,
als Selina zwei Jahre alt war.
Essen.
Es sind sicher schwere Sachen dabei.
Aber andererseits
war für mich immer schön,
dass es
keine degenerative Krankheit ist,
also immer schlechter wird
und bis zum Tod führt.
Es ist eine neurologische Erkrankung
und man kann in dem Sinne
alt werden.
Wenn man weiss, dass sie nie
mit anderen Kindern spielen kann ...
Diese Gedanken macht man sich.
Unsere Aufgabe ist es jetzt,
sie glücklich zu machen.
Ich muss dir ein Lätzchen umbinden.
Cederic Menzi hat einen kleinen
Bruder: den dreijährigen Sören.
Er selber
wird seit seinem dritten Lebensmonat
in den verschiedensten Therapien
gefördert
und seine Fortschritte
verwundern sein Umfeld und die Ärzte.
Doch trotz alledem:
Cederic bleibt schwer beeinträchtigt
und hat Mühe, sich zu konzentrieren.
Was träumst du wieder?
Es ist kein Weltuntergang.
Was willst du nicht?
Cederic.
Ist das Essen mit Cederic schwierig
oder wie ist das?
Ja, ich finde es schwierig.
Es ist nervenaufreibend.
Entweder passt ihm das Essen nicht
oder er spielt damit.
Er sollte sich
aufs Essen konzentrieren.
Das lernten wir in der Esstherapie.
Aber er spielt immer mit etwas.
Ab zu Mami.
- Was?
Cederic erhält seit seiner Geburt
eine Hilflosenentschädigung
der Invalidenversicherung.
Als es darum ging,
diese Leistungen zu erhöhen,
kam ein Vertreter der IV
zu Charlotte Menzi nach Hause.
Der Augenschein vor Ort -
ein traumatisches Erlebnis.
Ich will auch noch vieles.
Weisst du, was ich möchte?
Im Lotto gewinnen.
Ich schöpfte das Essen
und im Bericht hiess es,
ich hätte
eine riesige Portion gegeben.
Man gebe Kindern doch
nur ein bisschen und schöpfe nach.
Er schob dann das Essen rum
und in dem Schreiben
stand wortwörtlich ...
... dass ich mein Kind
fast zum Essen genötigt hätte.
Er kriegt
dreimal pro Tag Medikamente.
Er braucht das Essen vor den Medis.
Sein Magen
wird durch das Epileptikum
und das andere Medikament
eh schon geschädigt.
Medis auf leeren Magen geben,
ist meiner Meinung nach
einfach nicht gut.
Das ist verletzend:
Die Leute urteilen über dich,
sind aber nur
für ein bis zwei Stunden hier.
Nein.
Nicht essen.
Ja, aber du findest, es sei nicht
gut, weil es der falsche Teller sei.
Gut. Gut, gut, gut.
Da, iss von diesem Teller!
- Nein, diesem.
Jetzt willst du doch
von diesem Teller,
sagst aber, er sei nicht gut?
Wie man es auch mache,
für die IV sei es nie richtig -
dies sei ihr Lebensgefühl,
sagt Cederics Mutter.
Man hat es ja eh schon schwer
mit dem Kind ...
... mit seinen Handicaps,
und dann muss man sich auch noch
mit solchen Sachen abquälen.
Wenn mein Kind gesund wäre,
wie sich das jeder wünscht,
müsste ich mir
den Stress nicht antun.
Charlotte Menzi
ist im dritten Monat schwanger.
Angst, dass ihr drittes Kind
ebenfalls mit einer Behinderung
geboren werden könnte,
habe sie keine, sagt die 39-Jährige.
Unter der Woche ist Charlotte Menzi
praktisch alleinerziehend.
Ihr Partner,
der Vater des kleinen Sören
und des ungeborenen Kindes,
ist Chauffeur und von frühmorgens
bis spät in die Nacht unterwegs.
Gut, jetzt brauche ich
die Wickel- und die Handtasche.
Allein ist sie darum auch oft
mit ihrer Verzweiflung über die IV -
z.B. wegen des langen Wartens
auf die Kostengutsprache für
einen Reha-Autositz mit Kopfstütze,
auf den Cederic
so dringend angewiesen ist.
Wir hatten den Sitz beantragt
und er wurde
ein erstes Mal abgelehnt.
Es stand irgendetwas
von wegen Kopfkontrolle.
Die habe er anscheinend.
Wegen der eigenen Kopfkontrolle
wurde er abgelehnt.
Erst aufgrund des zweiten Rezepts
wurde uns
der Kindersitz zugesprochen.
Wir kriegten ihn
kurz vor Weihnachten.
Beantragt
hatten wir ihn Anfang Jahr.
Es ist einfach ...
Es macht traurig und ist schade.
Man will das ja nicht,
weil man denkt,
man brauche das unbedingt für sich,
sondern
für die Sicherheit des Kindes.
Baba, halt, dort. Bobobo.
Rot ab. Halt, Mama.
Ja, richtig,
ich muss anhalten, weil Rot ist.
Aber bis ans Lichtsignal darf ich.
- Halt.
Was bedeutet das grüne Licht?
- Los.
Los. Genau.
Charlotte Menzi
ist nicht mehr berufstätig.
Zu kräfteraubend
sind Cederics Betreuung und Pflege.
Einmal pro Woche
bringt sie die beiden Buben
für 2 Std. zu einer Tagesmutter.
In dieser Zeit geht sie einkaufen
oder gönnt sich
eine Stunde im Fitnesscenter.
Er spielte etwas verrückt,
aber er ist gerne hier.
Nicht werfen.
Das ist ein Entlastungsdienst,
aber das Ganze wirkt etwas stressig.
Ja, wir haben 2 Std. pro Woche.
Das Kinderspital St. Gallen
stellte bei der Stiftung Cerebral
einen Antrag für mich,
damit ich wenigstens 2 Std. pro
Woche einen Entlastungsdienst habe.
Der Aufwand mit Cederic
ist ja relativ hoch,
auch nervlich.
Es wird viel abverlangt.
Es sind halt wirklich
nur diese 2 Std.
Den Rest müsste man selber bezahlen.
Sören kostet weniger, das ist klar,
aber wenn man
mit der Zeit übertreibt,
summiert sich das und das liegt
finanziell einfach nicht drin.
Ich bin wirklich froh,
dass die Stiftung Cerebral
uns das noch mal gegönnt hat.
Selina?
Heute pflegt eine Mitarbeiterin
der Kinderspitex Selina Matter.
Guten Morgen, Selina. Hallo.
Hatten Sie eine gute Nacht?
Ja, es ging eigentlich gut.
Ich stand ein paarmal auf,
um Selina umzulagern.
Das machen wir regelmässig,
damit sie nicht zu viele Stunden
auf der gleichen Seite liegt
und dann Druckstellen kriegt.
Dann wechselte ich noch ihre Windel.
Dann piepste ihre Maschine
noch zweimal.
Das ist so ein Alarmton.
Sie hat diese Maschine
ja jede Nacht,
damit sie eine bessere
Sauerstoffversorgung erhält.
Selinas Pflege nimmt jeden Tag
im Minimum 6 Std. in Anspruch.
Zwei- bis dreimal pro Woche
unterstützen Pflegefachfrauen
der Kinderspitex Isabelle Matter.
Das ist eine
sehr grosse Erleichterung für mich,
v.a. auch,
wenn sie z.B. am Tag hier sind
und mein Sohn in den Kindergarten
oder ins Fussballtraining muss.
Ich kann mich voll und ganz
auf die Spitex verlassen.
Sie geben Selina ihre Medis usw.
Sie kommen auch manchmal
für die Nacht,
damit ich mal
eine Nacht durchschlafen kann.
Selinas Mutter
ist ebenfalls Pflegefachfrau.
Mit ihrer Berufserfahrung
konnte sie Selina schon
manchen Spitalaufenthalt ersparen.
Sie macht das mit
sehr viel Feingefühl und Sorgfalt.
Und auch Liebe - wie jede Mami
ihre Tochter pflegen würde.
Wenn Selina
in der Heilpädagogischen Schule
und Dario im Kindergarten sind,
kämpft sich Isabelle Matter durch den
bürokratischen Dschungel mit der IV.
Um eine definitive Kostengutsprache
für die Leistungen der Kinderspitex
kämpfen Isabelle Matter und ihr Mann
schon jahrelang.
Was ist Ihr grösster Ärger?
Eigentlich, dass wir seit Mai 2017
immer noch an dem dran sind.
Wir haben so, so viele Stunden
dafür aufgebracht
und es gibt
immer noch keine Antwort.
Unsere Anwältin hat so viele Stunden
dafür aufgewendet
und die IV wahrscheinlich auch -
und das
für etwas so Offensichtliches.
Das zieht sich schon über
eine so lange Zeitspanne hinweg.
Niemand bei der IV
kann sich daran erinnern,
was wir vor vier Jahren
eingereicht haben.
Es ist einfach zu viel Papier.
Zurzeit sind ca. 2'600 Dokumente
für diesen Fall vorhanden.
So etwas sollte einfach
in einer realistischeren Zeitspanne
abgewickelt werden können.
Die IV des Kantons Luzern
beurteilt den Fall "Selina Matter"
als aussergewöhnlich vielschichtig.
Aus unserer Beurteilung
dauerte es nicht vier Jahre,
aber aus Sicht der Familie
und nach unserer Einschätzung
dauerte es bei diesem sehr komplexen
und aufwendigen Fall doch zu lange.
Dafür entschuldigen wir uns.
Wir sind aber der Meinung,
dass wir die Leistungen,
die sie zugute haben,
immer wieder erbringen konnten.
Wir kamen nicht weiter.
Wir fanden keine Lösungen
mit der IV.
Wir mussten anfangen, über
die Stiftung, bei der wir sind ...
... mit Anwälten
Lösungen mit der IV zu finden.
Es sind einfach nur Zangengeburten.
Das kann man sich nicht vorstellen.
Tatsache ist, dass Familien,
die ihre Kinder selber betreuen,
verschiedene Leistungen
zugute haben
und diese bei uns beantragen.
Wir müssen abklären, ob die
Leistungen erbracht werden dürfen
und ob wir die Leistungen
bezahlen können.
Wir können nicht einfach sagen,
dass wir die und die Modalität sehen
und darum einfach bezahlen.
Das kann dazu führen,
dass unterschiedliche Beurteilungen
entstehen.
Man muss unterschiedliche
Blickwinkel berücksichtigen.
Das führt dazu, dass man nicht alles
partnerschaftlich beurteilen kann.
So, Selina, jetzt gehen wir raus.
Trotz alledem: Ihre Erfahrungen mit
der IV seien keineswegs nur negativ,
sagt Isabelle Matter.
Du kannst sie vorbereiten.
Hilfsmittel, Umbauten und Therapien
bezahle die IV anstandslos.
Man muss wohl immer gut überlegen,
damit man nichts vergisst, oder?
Das ist schon so.
Und ob man wirklich
aus dem Haus muss.
Und wenn,
dass man alles miteinander erledigt.
Es dauert schon ziemlich lange.
Auch die Fahrtkosten
zu allen Therapien und Arztbesuchen
werden von der IV übernommen.
Und Isabelle Matter
ist viel mit Selina unterwegs.
Kombiniert mit Arztterminen,
Physio, Hilfsmittel usw.
sind es rund 100 Termine pro Jahr.
Einer davon ist die regelmässige
Anpassung von Selinas Orthesen,
die verhindern, dass ihre Gliedmassen
sich verkürzen oder verformen.
Möchtest du mitkommen?
Ziehen wir die rechts als Erstes an?
Schau mal, was du gekriegt hast:
Ich glaube, Herr Wechsler
hat gesagt, das sei ein Schaffell.
Genau.
Damit du morgens
nicht mehr rot bist.- Schön.
Wir schauen uns
auch noch die andere Seite an.
Um Infektionen ihrer Atemwege
zu verhindern,
muss Selina
mehrmals täglich inhalieren.
Sie inhaliert überall und jederzeit.
- Überall.
Ich versuche mich im Multitasking.
Würde ich alles nacheinander machen,
wäre ich um 22.15 Uhr noch dran.
Gut, tschüss.
- Tschau miteinander.
Tschau, Wiedersehen. Dario?
So,
jetzt noch das Lätzchen umbinden.
Reinschlüpfen.
Mira Schönholzer,
zweieinhalb Jahre alt.
Schon im Alter von zwei Monaten
bemerkte die Kinderärztin,
dass mit Miras Muskelaufbau
etwas nicht stimmte.
Bald stellte sich auch heraus,
dass Mira mit den Reizen
aus ihrer Umwelt nicht klarkommt.
Dies führte zu bisweilen wochenlangen
Schreiphasen, die bis heute anhalten.
Sie hat
eine Entwicklungsverzögerung.
Momentan ist sie auf dem Stand
einer Halb- bis Einjährigen.
Beim Essen ist sie relativ weit.
Sie kann schon Stückchen essen,
z.B. Brötchen. Sie ist hungrig.
Sie kann schon Brotstückchen nehmen.
Aber frei zu sitzen
kommt für sie noch nicht infrage.
Auch die Kommunikation
ist schwierig.
Ich verstehe in dem Sinn nicht,
was sie will.
Sie hat ein bisschen Lärm gemacht,
was bedeutet,
dass ihr etwas nicht passt.
Aber was, kann ich anhand
ihrer Kommunikation nicht zuordnen.
Mira, Mira, Brötchen.
Yummy, yummy.
Mira.
Woran Mira genau leidet,
wissen Christina Schönholzer
und ihr Mann nicht.
Schiene auf. Du kannst rauskommen.
Du weisst, wie das geht. Hier auch.
Genau. Nach vorne und aufstehen.
Stehen. Mira, steh.
Stehst du? Da.
Trotz ihrer
offensichtlichen Beeinträchtigung
liegt keine Diagnose
für Miras Behinderung vor.
Darum hat die IV ihre Zahlungen
an Familie Schönholzer eingestellt.
Keine Diagnose,
keine IV-Ziffer für Geburtsgebrechen,
keine Leistungen für Mira.
Die IV des Kantons Thurgau
nimmt dazu nur schriftlich Stellung:
Diese Antwort raubte
auch Christina Schönholzer den Atem.
Sag Tschüss.
Tschüss.
Pass auf, okay?
Wir holen dich hier wieder.
Ja.
- Tschüss.
Die Gesamtsituation
ist einfach riesig belastend.
Man weiss nicht,
wie es weitergehen wird.
Es ist von morgens bis abends streng
und nachts wacht sie vielleicht
auch noch ein-, zweimal auf.
Man kann gar nie
richtig runterfahren.
Sie jemandem abzugeben,
ist fast unmöglich.
Tagsüber für 3 bis 4 Std.
ist das kein Problem,
aber mal wieder
8 Std. schlafen können ...
Das ist schon sehr belastend.
* Mira ächzt. *
Ja.
Die Krankenkasse
übernimmt wohl die Kosten
für die medizinischen Massnahmen.
Leistungen
wie die Vergütung von Fahrtkosten
oder die Finanzierung
von Therapiegeräten
bleiben den Schönholzers
aber verwehrt.
Bleib sitzen, um zu essen.
Für ihre weitere Entwicklung
bräuchte Mira dringend ein Stehbrett,
um ihre Umwelt
auch aus einer aufrechten Perspektive
wahrnehmen zu können.
Doch dafür fühlen sich
weder Krankenkasse noch IV zuständig.
Stütz dich mit dem Arm ab
und dann über die Seite nach oben.
So ist gut.
Ist es kein Thema, das Brett
auf eigene Kosten anzuschaffen?
Wenn man sich das
auf eigene Kosten anschafft,
heisst es dann, man habe es ja schon
und es werde nicht bezahlt.
Den Therapiestuhl, den Mira
u.a. zum Essen am Tisch benötigt,
beantragten Schönholzers
noch vor Miras zweitem Geburtstag.
Sollten Anpassungen nötig werden,
müsste die Familie
diese selbst berappen.
Und: Mira wächst und wird schwerer.
Bald wird sie nicht mehr
in diesen Therapiestuhl passen.
Es nervt extrem,
durch die Maschen zu fallen.
Das alles ist schlussendlich
auch eine Energiefrage.
Die ganze Bürokratie
braucht wahnsinnig viel Energie -
und auch das Unwissen.
Das alles ist sehr komplex.
Man muss sich das Wissen
erst aneignen und Hilfe holen.
Hilfe zu holen, ist das Erste:
Wo holt man die?
Es ist schwierig,
Informationen zu finden.
Mithilfe eines Gentests
soll jetzt eine Diagnose für
Miras Behinderung gefunden werden,
damit sie zu einer IV-Ziffer
und so zu IV-Leistungen kommt.
Die Chancen, dass der Gentest
eine Diagnose liefern kann,
liegen bei 60 %.
Familie Schönholzer
wird durch den Rechtsdienst
der Selbsthilfeorganisation Procap
vertreten.
Fälle wie dieser
sind oft zu kompliziert,
zu kräfteraubend und bisweilen
auch emotional zu belastend,
als dass sie ohne Rechtsbeistand
zu bewältigen wären.
Man hat ein Kind mit Behinderung,
was viel Zusatzaufwand bedeutet.
Man muss viel Freizeit,
viele Hobbys und Partnerschafts-
anliegen hinten anstellen.
Und als Dessert
darf man auch noch dafür zahlen.
Das ist extrem ungerecht.
Aber es gibt
gewisse Regelungen im Gesetz,
welche die IV einhalten muss.
Da muss ich sie in Schutz nehmen.
Wenn ein Behandlungsgerät
notwendig ist,
aber kein Geburtsgebrechen vorliegt,
m u s s  die IV das ablehnen.
Das ist nicht ein Fehler der IV,
sondern der Gesetzgebung.
Da liegt es an uns: Wir können
das Gesetz jederzeit ändern,
dafür braucht es aber eine Mehrheit.
Ist gut?
Ist alles gut?
Ja?
Du kannst auswählen,
welchen Pyjama du möchtest.
Welchen möchtest du heute?
Den hier?
Du siehst nur den an.
Also, wir nehmen den.
Super.
Selina Matter leidet
unter nächtlichen Atemaussetzern.
Ausserdem kann
eine einfache Infektion der Atemwege
brandgefährlich für sie werden -
Selina könnte ersticken.
Darum gehört das Einrichten
des Überwachungsgerätes
zu Selinas allabendlicher Routine.
Wir legen das noch drunter.
* Selina wimmert. *
Selina, ich habe eine Idee:
Wir machen die Musik an. Hm?
Ist das gut?
* Selina wimmert. *
Machen wir die Musik an? Hm?
(Flüsternd) Ist das gut?
(Flüsternd) Machen wir die Musik an?
Hm?
Ich interpretiere,
dass Selina wohl sehr müde ist
und einfach ihre Ruhe möchte,
damit sie endlich einschlafen kann.
Ich finde es schön,
dass sie die Fähigkeit hat,
uns das mitzuteilen.
Man hört ja ein Weinen.
Wir verstehen,
dass es ihr nicht mehr passt.
Dass sie das kann,
ist eine von Selinas Stärken.
Selina ist bei uns.
Wir pflegen sie hier.
Wir haben Unterstützung usw.,
wir müssen aber auf viel verzichten.
Das nehmen wir in Kauf,
das passt so für uns.
Das wollten wir auch so.
Aber noch einmal: Wir erwarten,
dass die Institution IV
ein seriöser Partner für uns ist.
Sie muss uns kein Geld ausschütten
und uns beschenken.
Sie soll ein guter Partner sein,
mit dem man zusammenarbeiten kann.
Unsere Grundhaltung ist:
"Mit Menschen für Mitmenschen".
D.h., dass wir zusammen
auf diesen Weg gehen wollen.
Wir sehen,
dass die Eltern viel Aufwand haben.
Wenn es aber darum geht,
wie viele Pflegeleistungen
und in welchem Umfang,
müssen wir abklären,
was sie zugute haben,
was die Spitex, was die Assistenten
und was die Familie macht.
Dass wir da am Schluss nicht immer
zum gleichen Ergebnis kommen,
ist leider Tatsache.
Das können wir nicht verhindern.
Aber es ist nicht so,
dass wir gegen Familien arbeiten,
die einen grossen Aufwand
für ihre Tochter erbringen.
* Er spricht unverständlich. *
Jetzt musst du aufstehen.
Gehst du selber hinauf?
- Nicht höher rauf.
Nein, dann kannst du direkt
ganz nach oben.
Ja, genau.
* Er spricht unverständlich. *
Du Katastrophenkind.
Das Pièce de Résistance
in Charlotte Menzis Alltag:
Cederics anstrengendes Abendritual.
Du hinlegen.
"Nach dem Picknick will Christopher
Robin die Eule besuchen."
Sie muss neben
ihrem schwer hirngeschädigten Sohn
so lange liegen bleiben,
bis dieser eingeschlafen ist,
sonst nimmt der Tag
gar kein Ende mehr.
Müde.
- Pu ist müde.- Ja.
Nach über einer Stunde -
endlich Ruhe.
In der Zwischenzeit
ist auch Charlotte Menzis Partner
nach Hause gekommen.
Ich würde gerne
in einer Bude arbeiten.
Und jetzt, nach einem langen Tag:
Formulare für die IV ausfüllen.
Ich habe keinen Plan mit den Daten.
Das ist katastrophal.
Ich könnte mich nicht darauf
konzentrieren, das auszufüllen,
wenn die Kinder um mich herum sind.
Das hat mehr damit zu tun.
Man wird dauernd abgelenkt.
Dann passieren Fehler.
Ich brauche für die Büroarbeit
wirklich Konzentration.
Es geht auch um etwas,
wenn man Fehler macht, oder?
Ja, schon. Das ist mitunter
halt Geld, das fehlt.
Und das, ja, das müsste nicht sein.
Fest. Du kannst mithelfen.
So, jetzt gehen wir nach hinten.
Was machen wir,
wenn wir zum Tisch kommen?
Die Hände fest nach oben.
Mira hat ihr Stehbrett erhalten.
Ihre Eltern haben es gebraucht
in Deutschland gefunden.
Ein Happy End
mit bitterem Nachgeschmack:
Der Verein Sternentaler ist für IV
und Krankenkasse eingesprungen
und hat Familie Schönholzer
die Kosten für das dringend benötigte
Therapiegerät erstattet.
Wir erfreuen uns
an den schönen Momenten.
Bei ihr gibt es sehr viele.
Das stimmt die ganze Familie
positiv.
Wir haben
auch noch ein gesundes Kind.
Und mit Selina passt es.
Wir sind glücklich.
Sie nimmt an so vielen Sachen teil.
Sie strahlt sehr viel Freude aus.
Das gibt so viel zurück.
Und - nach einem
jahrelangen Rechtsstreit mit der IV -
hat Familie Matter
nun auch endlich die Kostengutsprache
für die Kinderspitex erhalten.
Es ist ein Geschenk, dass Selina
in unsere Familie kommen durfte.
Wir können das bewältigen.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021